it's coming from the sorrow in the
street the holy places where the raises
meat from the homicidal bitching that
goes down in every kitchen to determine
who will serve and who will eat coming
to America first the cradle of the best
lures it's here they got the reigns and
the machinery of change and it's here
they got the spiritual thirst I'm
sentimental if you know what I mean
I love the country but I can't stand the
scene and I'm neither left or right I'm
just staying home tonight
get lost hopeless scream from the wars
against disorder from the sirens night
and day
democracy is coming to the USA hey guys
Pete here there's good news mr. robot
has dropped a new trailer for season
three and we have an official release
date of October 11th 2017 way they
released this trailer was amazing and
I'll talk about that later but real
quickly if you're watching this as a fan
of my channel but don't necessarily
watch mr. robot like you watch my
channel for other shows I highly
recommend this show it's packed full of
mystery there are great characters
mind-bending twists in every episode is
packed with Easter eggs like everything
narG clues which make the week's in
between episodes like a non-stop
immersive experience it's really one of
the best in most underrated shows out
there they released a companion book in
the off season which added even more
depth to the last one and I think like
just flat-out it is the most underrated
show and experience going on TV so I'll
put some links in the description to
where you can find some of that stuff
but definitely check it out if you've
never seen it so the trailers out I'm
going to break it down frame by frame
luckily everything is pretty clear as
far as who we see so there's not a lot
of mystery in that and yeah let's jump
into it so the first theme is Darlene
walking through a street full of people
camping sort of like a tent city almost
but it's interesting to note that it's
right out in the neighborhood you know
this is an under bridge or an abandoned
parking lot or something we can see the
effects of what's been going down since
the 5/9 hack is hitting looks like
people are sort of living out there in
the street after that we see Eliot he is
passing through a subway station we see
that people are wearing surgical masks
here and I'm wondering if this is in
relation to all the trash we saw piled
up powering up last season and it's kind
of interesting to think about the fact
here
the subway still seems to be running so
some parts of the infrastructure are
still functioning at least here and we
will see someone on the train later on
the subreddit someone pointed out that
this could be catching a train to Coney
Island but as a non New York New York or
I have no idea how you would even be
able to tell something like that I mean
a bridge the subway in New York but I
have no expertise and the next scene we
see a shot that looks to be like
underneath a big building we see sort of
pipes and ductwork that looked to be you
know something you would see on a
subterranean floor it looks like Elliott
he's struggling to pull himself up but
that's about all we see here after that
we get another shot of Elliott this one
we're sure it's him we see his face he's
standing in a room with a bookshelf that
has already booked behind him he's sort
of touching his face and he looks in
anguish I'm sure someone will zoom in
and check out what all those books
actually are but from this distance I
can't tell that the books themselves are
any more important than what we see in
the next one we see mr. robot he's in a
room it's sort of dark there is some
light there but it's not lit overhead
this could be related to where we see
him in a little bit but he has a look of
disbelief or something like he can't
believe what he just heard or what he
just saw then we get one that stands out
right away in that Philip price and
tyrell wellick looking at something
together and they're in Tyrells home the
reason I say it stands out right away is
because this could be out of sequence
with the normal timeline but there's
honestly no way to tell because when
Tyrell finally came back he dressed
exactly the same as he did before he
disappeared and even though that would
be a strange meeting for price to be
with him especially in his home we
really don't know then we see Angelo
based on the hair wearing a black hoodie
and an F Society mask that is obviously
smeared with a substance it seems most
likely that this would be blood we can't
really tell where she's at it's the Cure
building and
you know she's leaving a room this could
be related to the other scene we see of
her but not much way to tell forget the
one and only shot of dum de Pierrot next
she has a gun drawn with a flashlight
she is gaining the room or clearing the
room something along those lines and you
can't really tell at first I thought it
was maybe a bathroom or it could be a
storage or utility closet or something
along that lines then we see a guy with
a gun wearing an F Society mask and the
suit first thought it was Tyrell but if
you look at the hair it's definitely
somebody else not someone that we know
or not someone that I found recognizable
right away so this could be a new
character or it could just be a random
character that's acting out in the
aftermath of the hack we see a yellow
taxi being followed by a black car we've
seen Johanna in her driver protector you
know being driven around mr Sutherland
in a black car but I can't say that
that's the case it's an SUV and that's
what she has but you can't really tell
we see BD Wong who plays white rose but
he's in his ministers a Jiang persona
his male persona he didn't what looks
like probably a limousine or could be
some other kind of car but you can tell
that he has a I'm keeping thought look
on his face and the curtains are all
sort of drawn around him so no one can
see inside we get another shot of Tyrell
not looking very Tyrell except for the
way he's dressed now when I first saw
this I thought this was outside based on
some of the things that were going on
like the fire and the bucket and the
chair looks like a you know outdoor lawn
furniture kind of thing but on reddit
they said he was in a room sitting on a
bed so chime in below and tell me what
you guys think about this but the big
part of the scene is is that he is
taking a bottle of vodka to the head in
a pretty serious manner like he is he's
chugging it down we then see a shot of
Darlene crying she appears to be in a
room not much detail I mean there's a TV
there looks pretty sparse as far as
everything else goes we get our first
look at Bobby Carnival and he is
definitely with people wearing dark army
max who are holding guns and this looks
like it is in the arcade which is also
very strange like that they would be
there since the FBI's already you know
search that location we'll talk more
about Bobby carnival later let's see we
have this theme it's pretty hard to make
out it looks definitely like Darlene and
Elliott he's walking behind her they're
walking on like a glass floor it looks
someone like a party up on the top part
and then when you look through you see
it looks like there's a bunch of people
on computers almost like an office space
or something I mean their initial
thought I had here is this is some kind
of new F Society place where people
gather but you know you can't tell
really after that we see that people are
protesting at the Ecore building there's
a security guard he's kind of getting
rushed as he comes up to one of these
guys looks like [ __ ] is going down in
their Lobby next one appears to be
Darlene looking worried looking through
people in a door then we see Angela
walking she's in an office building it
looks like it's an you know the Ecore
place because there's a security guard
with an e corp jacket and we see that
they're sort of graffiti scrawled on the
walls and things like that
let me see mr. robot at a terminal and I
brought up the lighting in the in the
last one because we see the same kind of
lighting here Tyrells at his side and
initially I thought this may be in the
past but it looks like Bobby Carnivale
and Angela are behind him and so if
Angela's there with someone who we see
is associated with the dark armies and I
have to imagine that this is not in the
past because she didn't switch sides
until the end of the season well then
see someone's come into Elliot's
apartment they look Chinese they look
like they are thugs for lack of a better
term you know criminal guys they have
guns drawn they're looking for something
or looking for him we see a checkpoint
it says security checkpoint and see a
black SUV they're being pulled over they
have a dog a sniffer dog and then the
final scene we see the II Corp sign and
then as it pans up we see that Elliot is
at the E Corp headquarters so ton of
stuff and it's all pretty exciting
really I saw this first thing this
morning when I woke up I thought asleep
last night when they were teasing it so
I went through grab dogs screenshots
made notes and then I went over to the
mr. robot subreddit which is one of the
best subreddits for a TV show that there
is and I compared my notes first let's
look at what we didn't see though
because that's a little bit easier we
saw a lot of Tyrell which we heard we're
going to get a lot more Tyrell in this
season but we saw no Johanna
we didn't get any sightings of
threatenin Mosely or Leon out west there
were no scenes with Phillip price and
any other character besides Tyrell like
we didn't see him being Phillip price
very much and like I said the Tyrell
scene definitely stands out we didn't
see any themes with white Rhodes as
herself
we also learned in the off season that
Dom has a new partner who's played by
actor Rizwan mangy and we did not see
him yet so yeah what we did see was a
lot of Tyrell Tyrell was price Tyrell
with mr. robot and Tyrell alone in a
room or outside drinking vodka straight
to the face we thought Elliot and
Darlene together which is kind of big I
guess I mean these are these weren't
things that we didn't think would happen
but Darlene is no longer in FBI custody
or wherever she was and Elliot is
walking around and seems to be healed
from his gun shot that he took with
Darlene out and about it
she wonder where she's at we know that
from what Sam s mouth said that Angela
is definitely on the side of the dark
army something about what was going on
and white roses plan has convinced her
that that's where she wants to be so we
didn't see any scenes with her in price
senior White Rose dressed as Minister
Jang could be important but we don't
really know the city is definitely
falling further into despair we saw the
protesters we saw all of that people
camping living on the street maybe trash
piling up continuing and then we had the
subway rider pulling the gun which may
be an indication that things are getting
more and more desperate post five nine
and we also learned that even though
they said Bobby Carnivale would be
playing a used-car salesman he also
happens to be in bed with the dark army
so yeah I was just really exciting they
drop some clues for people to solve and
they release the text to the song by
Leonard : democracy which is the you
know the voiceover in the video trailer
and then eventually dropped the full
trailer I mean it's not a full trailer
it's a teaser for sure but a lot to
think about
it's really getting exciting we have an
actual date now so even though it's a
little bit off it should be more stuff
to look at in the meantime this video
already got long so I'm going to cut it
off here I am going to do some more mr.
robot videos on the lead up to season 3
I read the red wheelbarrow book a few
months ago so I'm going to go back
through that make a video about that
I'll put a link to it that in the
description if you haven't seen it yet
it's pretty awesome definitely
interesting and real fans are going to
want to have that I would imagine we'll
also look at any and all images that
come out and different trailers that
they release over time
CMS ml has done a lot of interviews and
given up some pretty interesting stuff
to go over
so yeah please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel and then make sure you hit that
Bell for notifications I do a pretty
full schedule of releases now
you're going to want to have
notifications to make sure you don't
miss anything follow me on Twitter and
my other social media accounts and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon
you